you
in the first two parts of our three-part
series we explored the procedures in
place for first contact and the possible
stances intelligent beings could take on
humanity in this final installment we're
going to take a look at the potential
social legal and theological
ramifications of alien arrival before we
start looking at the possibilities let's
establish our baseline these
hypothetical scenarios only work if the
aliens we encounter are at least
somewhat similar to humans in terms of
biology and intellect with such a vast
universe out there who knows what form
intelligent life could take for the sake
of this video we're going to assume that
the aliens we encounter are roughly
similar to humans in all the necessary
ways to allow communication between our
species in today's world it seems we've
seen new acts of violence hatred and
xenophobia everyday humans as a species
have a history of disagreement war
subjugation and distrust what if we
added extraterrestrial beings to the mix
would all of our differences suddenly
seem inconsequential
how would you manatee respond to so
radically change aliens living side by
side with humans has long been explored
in science fiction everything from star
trek to district 9 to call each having
their own interpretation of how well the
different species would get along when
district 9 was released back in 2009 it
sparked some interesting conversation
what if aliens arrived and they're not
here to destroy us or to help us what if
they're simply refugees and need a place
to stay for a while in the film aliens
were forced to live in slums and anti
alien sentiment was prevalent many
people considered this creative choice
to be a commentary on contemporary race
relations especially considering the
clear parallel to apartheid South Africa
apartheid was a very dark period in
South African history officially lasting
from 1948 to 1991 it was a system of
institutionalized racial segregation
under apartheid housing and employment
opportunities were dictated by race put
simply black suffered worse and worse
discrimination over the years often
being subjected to social exclusion
forced relocation and violence at the
hands of the white ruling class
officially that's all behind us but it's
clear that even today these social
problems still exist whether we like to
admit it or not humans tend to group
together with people like themselves and
ostracize those who are different that
doesn't bode well for any
extraterrestrials who decide to stop by
of course
alien rival could also be a good thing a
giant tentacled monster landing on earth
could help humans realize that we're all
one species after all and perhaps our
differences aren't as vast as we think
what about the legal ramifications say
an alien lands on the White House lawn
as aliens often do he obviously has no
passport or citizenship anywhere on
earth so what do we do with him
initially such visitors may only have
the protection of animal cruelty
statutes as they're not human and
therefore have no human rights however
if the alien were sufficiently humanoid
in appearance it's no stretch of the
imagination that the governments of the
world would be more willing to classify
them as something for lack of a better
term more significant than animals but
where would that distinction put our
alien friend what rights would it afford
him probably not many if we learned
anything from history not even a hundred
years ago women couldn't vote in the
United States of course it's clearly a
very different situation one problem
that our alien friend might have
particular trouble with especially if he
arrives within the next four to eight
years is that he would technically be an
illegal immigrant unfortunately for him
there's really no way around that
he can't exactly go through the proper
immigration process without physically
being on earth hopefully the president
would make an exception to his current
stance on immigrants and refugees
otherwise children decades from now will
read in their history books how we
deported the first alien ever to visit
planet Earth perhaps the most
interesting effect of alien arrival
would be its impact on world religions
while religious beliefs vary widely
around the world most holy books would
require a thorough reinterpretation to
come to terms with the existence of
other intelligent beings the United
States would likely face the biggest
religious crisis because of its high
population of evangelical Christians
along with several other fundamentalist
branches extraterrestrial life would be
especially problematic for Christianity
because of its geocentric nature many
practicing Christians hold the opinion
that the earth is unique and special to
God and indeed earth is so far the
planet best suited to life as we know it
but if aliens were to make themselves
own it would likely cause a crisis of
faith in many conservative Christians
however in one survey of people with
many different religious beliefs people
indicated that their faith would not be
affected by the discovery of
extraterrestrial intelligence such
surveys tend to show that only a small
percentage of the religious population
would consider their beliefs
fundamentally contradicted by alien life
perhaps the closest comparison one can
currently make is to the advent of the
theory of evolution as many believe the
biblical creation story is directly
contradicted by the process of evolution
there's been a fundamentalist backlash
against it on the other hand we've also
seen many religious people accept the
fact that evolution is undeniable and
integrate that into their belief system
this theological flexibility will
definitely be required in the case of
intelligent alien life two more
possibilities are that our alien
neighbors may dismiss the religions
earth instead providing us a natural
explanation for everything or eliminate
religion as we understand it and
introduce humanity to an
all-encompassing face of course this is
all speculation
who knows how we would interact with
extraterrestrial intelligence even if
they do share similar physiology and
communication methods it would be such a
monumental change that everything we
know about social progress and legal
procedure could be thrown out the window
alien arrival would require a massive
overhaul of national and international
law social accommodations and religious
interpretation as for what society would
look like after this metamorphosis is
complete who can say we'll just have to
wait to find out be sure to check out
the links in the description if you'd
like to read more about the topics
covered in this video
come join the second thought family on
discord follow the link in the
description to find a great place to
chat with other subscribers contributors
and me if you enjoyed this video please
take a moment to subscribe to my channel
your support really does make a big
difference feel free to leave a like or
a dislike as you please and leave a
comment down below with how you think
society would change with alien arrival
you can watch parts 1 & 2 of this video
by clicking here or binge watch all of
my videos by clicking here thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
video
you
[Music]